Jesse physics the first law is what I
call it the inertia law
okay what's inertia you can always tell
from the main what inertia is it comes
from the same word where we get you're
not what doesn't mean when something is
in that it means well it means what of
what Camus we've talked about in that
sandwich is so in my head right now very
frustrating right what is it
haters gonna hate
fakers gonna fake there's another one
what's your line heartbreak is gonna
break that's right okay now here's the
point
if something's doing something it
doesn't want to change right in that
means don't don't change me whatever I'm
doing let me do it right so inertia let
me put some more language on it right
it's that um things want to keep doing
whatever they're doing and we're not
talking about people but we have objects
particles bodies okay
physics people tell me if I'm doing
anything this is fun initiatives right
yeah cool okay good now this is this is
um this is what it's about
this is my informal way of saying let me
give you the formal first law of our
community first law relation okay
now by the way it's one sentence but I'm
going to break it up into four clauses
so that we can explain it okay so here's
how it works cause one a body remains
mm-hmm at rest or in uniform straight
line
promotion course to those three unless
it is acted on fourth and last by a
nonzero resultant force into question
okay so let's look at this
a body so that's their that's their word
for particle objects all interchangeable
something okay it remains so if you can
see it wants to keep doing whatever it's
doing it doesn't want to change that is
its inclination that's what inertia
means at rest or in uniform
straight-line motion these are the two
alternatives for not changing right
either
I'm not moving and I don't want to move
or I'm moving I'm just I'm just tracking
along and I want to keep on doing the
exact same thing I'm not turning I'm not
accelerating I'm not slowing down
uniform in a straight line right so
these are the two versions of not
changing that's what they look okay
unless it's acted on so something
something must influence it right
something must influence it from the
outside right and that outside Theory
call is a force but importantly is right
here this it must be a nonzero resultant
force so you remember we're talking
before about me standing here and not
moving okay so I'm I'm remaining at rest
the reason why is because there are two
forces acting on me one up and one down
right but the result of the two forces
right let's destroy
they're anatomically accurate okay
you've got you've got gravity pulling
down right and then you've got the floor
or specifically the electromagnetic
force the poles together the atoms
they're pushing back up on you okay and
these two exactly cancel out the
resultant force is zero right so in
order to actually get me moving to
overcome my inertia right either
gravity's got to get stronger or I've
got to get on a trampoline something
like that so that the resultant force is
going in some other direction that makes
sense